una ansiada apertura la industria
turística cubana aguarda la vuelta de
visitantes tras la pandemia pero teme
que las restricciones a los viajes desde
eeuu impuestos por el exmandatario
donald trump frenen la recuperación el
mercado norteamericano nos podría ayudar
en el corto plan sobre todo a
levantarnos muy rápido lamentablemente
si hay dificultad con los vuelos
dificultad con los con los boletos
aéreos que están muy costosos y
difíciles va a ser para ellos cada vez
más complicado organizar un viaje y
venir en 2016 al final del segundo
mandato de barack obama el entonces
presidente relajó las restricciones de
viaje a la isla y aumentó la frecuencia
de vuelos el turismo desde eeuu se
multiplicó al alcanzar el medio millón
de visitantes estadounidenses en 2018 y
la economía cubana lo agradeció pero ese
mismo año trump revirtió la medida
poniendo fin a los cruceros reduciendo
los vuelos a la habana y eliminando los
que iban a otras provincias algo que
supuso un duro golpe que aún fue peor
durante la pandemia estamos esperándolo
con muchas ansias el turismo
norteamericano los familiares
y cubanoamericanos los nacidos allá que
tienen raíces acá es un turismo que
tenemos ahí a poca distancia y esperemos
que las relaciones se establezcan para
bien para volver a revivir lo que
tuvimos una vez con obama ahora la
esperanza está depositada en que la
administración byd en retomé la conexión
con cuba algo que parece complicado ya
que las relaciones entre los dos países
volvieron a tensarse desde las protestas
opositoras en la isla